hello everyone this is Samir from audio
science review I've gotten a number of
requests to do more tutorials on how to
read the measurements uh when I post a
review on audio science review so I
thought I uh created a new series now
I'm explaining the the measurements but
also to teach you to be able to assess
them very very quickly
um when I post a review uh usually you
see in about two three minutes somebody
commenting uh some device good or bad
and they might come as a shock to some
of you have never seen measurements or
how somebody could you know read their
review that fast but if you stick around
actually read the reviews for a few
months on on ASR you'll also gain the
same knowledge
my goal in this video is to teach you
that so that you could just scan the the
measurements and and what state and
review and arrive at the conclusion
quickly uh reason for that is that I do
a review almost every day and if you
want to keep up you better be quick at
this some things and and uh
that's what this is about
um you're going to notice that I'm going
to speak a lot faster to the tune of the
uh the theme of these videos and then to
keep them shorter so if you want to slow
it down use the YouTube controls to slow
down my voice
okay I thought I'd start with a review
of a deck that I did a few weeks ago
from a new company called uh zidoo they
have a sub brand name called ever solo
and they submit these Z8 DAC and it's a
very attractive lovely looking deck it
has a graphical user interface and you
can actually select view meters and such
and I really enjoyed playing with it and
the reason I show you this is because it
has as you'll see state-of-the-art
performance and should calibrate you on
what a great performing deck looks like
and then you know I'll show you an
example of of not so great deck
um
devices like this uh you know have
different outputs on them or inputs for
that map depending on what I'm testing
in case of Dax you either have RCA which
we call unbalanced or we have XLR which
are balanced that will become important
in a second when I talk about the output
voltages uh on this thing whenever you
buy a high-end deck make sure it at
least has XLR outputs
the inputs are the usual inputs of USB
USBS in this case as USBC which is
unusual and Optical and and coax input
and Bluetooth and what have you but
anyway uh my measurements are always
start with what's called a dashboard I
use an audio Precision analyzer that's
hiding down there and when you first run
this app
um that controls the analyzer it pops up
with the dashboard which you can
configure down here are what are called
meters you can tell it to show you
different measurements in the form of
both bar graphs in the middle over here
oh sorry you won't see my cursor and
um
and and some values in here and above
here are two Graphics when I first got
this analyzer I really thought that this
was a good snapshot of a performance of
a device where at a glance instantly and
in real time if you're sitting here you
can see the performance of the of the
device in case of the stack
um I feed it one kilohertz tone and
that's what this tone is over here and
that's what it looks like it's a sine
wave and that's what it sound wave looks
like and in an ideal deck we would just
see this spike in here and nothing else
we wouldn't see any noise to the left or
right of it and we wouldn't see these
spikes which are harmonic distortions or
otherwise they're just these are all the
extra junk that an ideal DAC wouldn't
have nothing's ideal in our world so
we're going to see some Distortion no
matter how good the device is and in
this case we see that this device does
have some Distortion but if we look at
the spikes in here this taller Spike or
the war spike is the second harmonic is
that two kilohertz it's a double the one
kilohertz and we see that it's below one
minus 130 that means 130 decibels lower
than the signal itself to give you a
perspective one is 115 is threshold of
hearing so this is the if this is the
loudest signal that you're playing
um if minus 115 is where the Distortion
lands it's inaudible in all conditions
for all content for all people so
provides a level of transparency
threshold so this device is 15 DB better
than that so it is way into transparency
so we're not bothered by these although
when it comes to ranking the best of the
best we do look at them but anyway
that's where my eye first goes to and I
look at the spray in here and then this
noise floors down here that is showing
this this noise4 is not the actual noise
floor I won't get into what it is but
for now you want it to be somewhere down
here as you can see just hugging the
bottom of the of the graph
then I usually glance at this number on
the left over here this is the voltage
that's coming out so if we look at the
uh what's called the RMS value of this
sine wave uh it uh coming it's if you
measure with a simple voltmeter it's
about 4.1 volts is what's coming out of
that XLR output uh the nominal an
improper my view output voltage for uh
any Source device is about four volts it
can go higher
but I don't excuse me I don't want it to
be lowered in this and this advice gets
there and just got a hair more than that
uh it's kind of I believe has a volume
control I don't remember to bring it
down but anyway it has four volts in
there and that's what I like to see so
if the XLR output all sends three volts
2.2 volts or some other number I'll note
that it's not good I've tested hundreds
of Dax that have Excel or output and and
they'll properly put out four volts uh
some parts of the industry haven't
gotten the news and they will up at
different levels and I'll talk about
that this value here is of no importance
it just tell me the frequency which I
said is one kilohertz and you already
see it this is an actual measurement so
sometimes it'll say you know 1.000 and
you may have a five at the end or point
zero point zero nine nine nine nine five
or something it's not Material sometimes
I find issues where this number is
jumping up and down you won't see it in
this snapshot but I'll note it but in
general this one is not very useful
what is useful as far as what summarizes
all this stuff is on the right and these
two displays are actually the two of the
same measurement but expressed two
different ways first one is THD plus n
ratio and that says look if we take the
uh this signal that's coming out with
that can we subtract our original wanted
signal one kilohertz whatever remains
has a certain energy it has a voltage
and we take a ratio of that voltage the
sum of these Distortion spikes and the
noise and we take a ratio of it that is
one kilohertz what is that percentage in
this case you know the percent is
extremely small so you got 0.000
and then that's a percentage so you got
two more zeros in there as far as ratio
these numbers are kind of hard to
remember even though this industry
standard measurement TST plus n that's
total harmonic Distortion plus noise and
uh a way to make this more
understandable is to take a log of that
and express it as a positive number and
that that is cyanide and this context
and so this these two numbers are the
same you could say this device has uh
this small number DHD plus n or you can
say it's got 123 DB signer so this you
know it's much easier number to play
with and that's what I and everybody
else that reads the Forum and goes by
rather than try to memorize what these
numbers look like
so but what does 123 mean is it was the
highest number 200 was the highest
number 125 we don't know right so what I
do is that and when I started doing long
long time ago I just created a running
table of of all the Sinead values that I
was getting and uh uh pretty soon that
graph became quite long and whenever a
device actually lands on the top what I
call top 20 I just showed that top 20 in
here and that's what I've done so this
is out of 400 some Dax that I've tested
this device landed in the number six
position now it's a bit of silliness in
here where I've got fraction of DB in
here the cyanide value actually varies
and that accuracy is just for fun the
main message in here is that this stack
landed in top 20. that's what you want
to walk away from uh walk away with
rather than it's you know number one or
number five it really doesn't matter it
just what matters is that it's state of
the art so here's an unknown company you
may have looked at their devices one I
would have looked at their device and
said hey what do they know about
producing good tax you know I've never
heard of ever Solo or Z do and who are
these guys and here you go measure this
in an instant snapshot says hey look I'm
state of the art you know the proper
Engineers out there designed this thing
and squash all sorts of noise and
Distortion that they could and landed in
their spots so almost always you could
actually stop here and predict what the
rest of the measurement is going to do
why because an engineer that sat hit
there and and minimized noise and
Distortion likely paid attention to
everything the stack was doing and a lot
of the other measurements are actually
uh uh if this these numbers aren't good
it pollutes the other ones too so a
cyanad isn't uh be all end all of of the
measurements but it's a very powerful
predictor of the rest of the performance
of of uh
um of the deck or amplifier what have
you it's a little bit like a our
performance if 060 is three seconds
chances are it doesn't you know uh have
Sloppy handling or you know lousy breaks
it's a good indication that something is
is well engineered and and this device
is but we don't stop there I I keep
going just in case we find issues
elsewhere you know we've developed the
rest of the test for a reason but as far
as speed reading in here is the voltage
correct yep four volts what's the sign
out where does it land in a table boom
wow this is already good so you could
stop here again and have a great
impression of you know how well
engineered the device is
now some of you don't have balanced
outputs and you want to know how well it
performs out of RCA output typically RCA
output is a little bit worse it can pick
up noise and it has lower output what's
the output that it should have two volts
or half of the four volts that XLR
output so we're looking over here for
two and here we again we want to look
for something that's at least 115 DB and
and this device it lands around 117. it
actually has a more of a penalty for
using RCA than many other devices that I
measure but actually does hit 6 DB no
actually it's all right it's all right
so usually there's a 6 DB difference in
in here between these two so
whether you use RCA output or XLR output
this is a state-of-the-art basically
performance
now some people say well look this is at
maximum volume I don't listen to maximum
volume what's the performance at less
than maximum volume so I run this test
and there's a new version of this I
won't talk about that's actually better
than this but I changed the input
digital values and measure the output
relative to the cyanide so the same sign
I would be talking about and we see that
if even if you drop the output there's
0.1 volt this uh DAC actually has 100 DB
sign at so and it is transparency at
like half a volt so performance is is
superb anyway I haven't found this to be
very revealing other than people use
them for comparison when you have other
designs like AVR sometimes have analog
volume controls that can make this thing
say something useful but this is more
informative for membership that that's
interesting but it's not informative is
this next number
uh people could argue you know how well
can people hear Distortion maybe they
can't even hear point one percent let
alone point zero zero zero zero one
percent but one thing you can hear is
noise and his coming out of your uh
speakers especially the Twitter and the
more sensitive your speaker is the more
you can hear it and the louder you play
the the more you could hear and so I
measured a dynamic range of of the deck
and there's a special technique in this
measurement to make sure that that
doesn't mute and full this measurement
but basically we measured what is the
loudest and uh that that can produce
versus what's the lowest signal that it
can produce and I measure both out of
XLR and RCA because again the output
voltages are different so the dynamic
range will be different so the left hand
side is XLR output balanced output and
right hand side is RCA unbalance and we
see that it produces 129 DB of uh signal
noise Ratio or dynamic range in this
case there's this they are the same
there's a slight distinction I won't get
into but for now just as soon they're
the same and so what this says is that
if your playback level is at 129 DB your
noise level will be at 0 DB okay our
hearing threshold is about -5 DB around
three to four kilohertz
so and you know 129 DB would be
exceedingly loud but there are concerts
you know people have measured in live un
Amplified conservative measured and it
can be 120 225 so if you're building
reference quality state of the art
you're producing you know live music you
want to get about you know 120 125 in
here I helped a little bit in
interpreting this number by dividing
this by six if we take any decimal
number divided by six it gives you what
is called equivalent number of bits or E
knob enob and I do that for you just to
divide by six and you get 21.5 in here
my Target in here is 20. 20 gives you
120 DBS of dynamic range with the noise
tool that essentially is inaudible so
anything above 20 is gravy and we have
21.5 by the way if you apply
Equalization a digital legalization you
eat into this Headroom so that's another
reason you want to have you know a
better number than you think you're
going to have uh you're going to need in
here RCA is a little bit worse as I
mentioned and we lose one and a half
bits of dynamic range in here but still
Excellence 20 bits so this gives you
noiseless system and if you haven't
heard this it's just a joy if you got a
system right now where you stick your
ear next to it to it or any here's more
buzz and then you know it switches to
one of these devices there's such a
relief to just hear nothing absolutely
nothing
okay so so far we've covered two types
of noise and distortion
people come back and often criticize
these tests and say well these are one
kilohertz so far the signal that we test
and what if I have more signals than
than one music isn't one so so fine
we'll go ahead and and use a synthetic
test uh that's 32 tones in it and that
this tone also runs at 192 kilos it
could be at lower frequencies but I like
the fact that it runs at a higher sample
rate so we measure wide bandwidth
performance of of the DAC anyway not
everything at 44.1 kilohertz and so
we've got 32 tones going in and when we
look at the Spectrum you'd see the 32
spikes an ideal DAC would have 32 of
these spikes and then the bottom in here
would fall off the chart will be nothing
again we don't have ideal devices so the
bottom in here falls down here it shows
basically either noise if it's random or
it shows intermodulation Distortion
which is Distortion that happens when
you have multiple tones in this case I
eyeballed this thing and I look at it
and I say yeah it's about it looks like
it's reaching about 130 DB going down
here what does 130 mean again it's a
kind of a hard number to digest so I
divide it by six and it gives us
equivalent number of bits of 22.5
remember my target is 20 bits of of uh
you know basically range of cleaning to
top of the signal and we have 22.5 bits
so that's exceptional performance you're
just more than you need extremely low
noise and you know not every device is
this good so looking at this thing you
just want to see noise floor down here
you don't if you know a lot of times you
actually see the noise floor climbing up
means the higher the frequency the more
noisy the device gets amplifiers tend to
do that and some Dax to it so you want
to see a flat response a very low number
and something above 20 over here
uh this test is a little bit harder to
explain but I'll try
um attack if you think about it as a
simplest uh device is that we give it a
digital value when we say produce this
voltage so if I said digital one I
wanted to get 0.1 volt if I said Digital
two it should give me 0.2 volts if I
said there's no 3A should give me 0.3
volts I'm making up these numbers the
actual numbers are hard to understand
because they're binary coded but uh for
the purpose of this discussion you know
that what I just described is a perfect
DAC if I double the input value digital
value that I tell to produce the output
should double if I triple it quadruple
and so forth and that's what this
measurement does it says let's start at
a minus 120 DB so we take our maximum
four volts that I showed you and we go
120 DB down and we give that digital
sample to the DAC and say produce that
that number better be minus 120 DB as a
measured voltage coming out of the DAC
so the two need to match one to one and
then if we show that as a deviation we
get this line as it says this this is
called a linearity test and he says the
ideal is 0 DB which means no variation
this stack Nails it as do everything
else in that top 20 graph and even
cheaper devices their docs are a hundred
dollars and still do this so this is a
requirement uh to happen again there's
special techniques behind the stack this
measurement which I won't go into if you
do it incorrectly you measure the wrong
thing but you want to see a flat line in
here it's not end of the world we get
little variations in here but you know
in anything more than a couple hundred
dollars that I expected to be you know
ruler flat in here meaning that
forgetting bad noise and Distortion we
get the proper output voltage whenever
we tell it this is the right input
okay
um Jitter is a fancy buzzword we have a
special signal we use to detect uh
Jitter and that special signal is called
the J Test signal it has a 12 kilohertz
tone it's actually not a tone but I will
go in the details of it but essentially
what you should see in this display is a
12 kilohertz spike in here because that
12 kilos exists in there this test is
run at 48 kilohertz sampling by the way
and embedded in there are uh is a little
square wave that generates these spikes
so it's a 24-bit level so you know these
bits in here an ideal DAC would have low
enough noise floor in here where you see
the sequence of uh little spikes showing
up so these are not bad things this
actually desired these little spikes
over here that start at -140 and go down
so we want to see a noise for this clean
and in here we don't want to see any
other spikes in here
you see some tiny things in here but
they're just incredibly low level low
level minus 150 and we just absolutely
don't care so this I call Perfect
and attest this thing with different
inputs
um Sometimes some inputs aren't as good
as others sometimes hustling may have
more Jitters sometimes USB although
that's less frequent uh it's sometimes
better coax also and uh show all three
inputs as far as Distortion as far as
Jitter note that uh many times Jitter is
actually created internally to the
device we usually think of Jitter as a
transmission line deficiency but uh many
times the device itself the DAC itself
generates enough internal noise that
messes with this clock and manifests
itself as Jitter and we also see other
spikes that are not Jitter but again
unwanted in here so
uh again that's what this is why ideal
one looks like I'll show you let's say
you know ideal pointing another attack
measure
um another example of a test we run
which is more than one tone is is this
intermodulation Distortion and the idea
here is instead of using one killer
Stone we use two tones and then see what
happens when we have both of them there
are different versions of this where
different frequencies different
amplitude I like this version from uh
organization called simty and that came
up with this idea of using a 60hz and a
seven kilohertz at the four to one
amplitude and the nice thing about this
that is basically measuring Distortion
at low frequency 60 hertz and high
frequency seven kilohertz at the same
time so we take the Distortion generate
but both tones combine them together and
express it as just one value and we plot
that an ideal device again would have
known to modulation Distortion and
there'll be nothing on this graph and we
don't get that now typical of some of my
measurements I show an upper and lower
bound these have picked for convenience
but they have worked out well this Top
Line is a Razer phone adapter that I
think is nine dollars or fifteen dollar
little thing you hook up to your USBC on
your phone and listen to music whether
than phones that don't have analog
output which is unfortunately most of
them and so that's a nine in ten dollars
it should be embarrassing for any any
product that costs more than 10 or 15
dollars to be up here where the yellow
line is and the blue line is this
topping dx3 Pro which is a 250 dollar
DAC that came out maybe three four years
ago I just left it in as a reference for
longest time many dags regardless of
price couldn't beat it and but certainly
this device which is seven hundred
dollars better beated and indeed it does
so if we look at the this red and pink
is the performance of this uh ever solo
deck and we can see that it beats the
top index 3 Pro uh with a very good
margin as I expect state of the art
decks to do and we see a declining line
which is what we want to see we don't
want to to start to tip up like the this
uh dongle does which means Distortion
has taken over the noise and and it's
going up so we want to have a line that
just goes down meaning that there's
noise and and we're just overcoming
noise in here and that's what we have in
here uh if you look squinting here you
see this little bit of a rise in
Distortion in here uh ESS Stacks from
company here says that build the Dax
silicon that's inside these larger boxes
very very common high performance stack
um has an issue that if you don't know
how to deal with it it'll actually
balloon up the Distortion up here I
coined that the es ESS DAC IMD hump
because it would generate a hump and for
the longest time this was unknown and
products were coming out with this uh
problem uh until I pointed out in review
of the reviews and good companies went
back and and had to find their own
solution ESS was of no help to them and
uh and so this there you can get brand
new Dax with this chip in it and we'll
have a giant hump in them because you
know they didn't know and they didn't
measure they'll pay attention to this
test so bottom line is for speed reading
you know depending on the price of the
product you want it to beat this blue
line and be down here uh you don't want
to be in in this region this day and age
okay
um these other tests are low perfunctory
but people are curious
um these Stacks are what is called over
sampling decks and have a digital filter
in there and that digital filter can be
programmed to either have a very sharp
response or have a slow response the
reason you need to have a filter at all
is because the whole process generates
sparious ultrasonic information which
you're supposed to chop off and instead
of having one algorithm in there and
having people argue whether that's the
best one or not most chip companies
actually give you a choice of many in
this case there's seven of them in here
and I plot the frequency response of of
these uh
um different filters so I changed the
filter run the test change the filter
run the test here you want to see
something that clears this 22 kilohertz
bandwidth because sampling rate is 44.1
kilohertz we want to see half of that
and not only does it clear that
bandwidth but it it lands at the lowest
point possible over here uh some of
these like you can see this blue one in
here it actually doesn't go very low and
that means it's not truncating all the
ultrasonic information some of them are
very slow as you can see these two over
here where they will allow then a lot
more of that Distortion to exist and
that will actually screw up the
performance elsewhere there's this
fallacy where people think this slow
filters are better no they're not better
so I'll show you over here what happens
with some of these slow filters you'll
see that with some of the slow filters
the response can actually be compromised
below 20 kilohertz and you know why you
know have a DAC that can't even produce
20 kilos properly so you want to have
the sharpest nicest filter and in this
case the default filter which is this
red one was the best one and you can see
that it goes out here and that's the
recommendation of me you know for you
know welcome to go muck with these
filters they're not part of the Pure
Performance of the device it's just a
functionality and I'll show you what
happens in here okay this one is not
perfunctory so
uh a lot of the measurements that match
that I mentioned are one or two or 32
frequencies but what happens at every
frequency and that's what this graph is
and so what we do is that we measure the
Distortion from 20 Hertz to 20 kilohertz
and see what we get this test is limited
to 90 kilohertz bandwidth for reasons I
won't go into But it includes harmonics
that happen all the way up in ultrasonic
range and this stack having a great
filter will produce a very nice linear
response and this dashed line is is a
older but good heat 99 DAC which broke
the price price barrier at the time uh
called The hadass Stone board and at 99
had this performance so you better be
below this whatever you do and the stack
is certainly below that so we want to
see a flat line if we can get it which
means there's frequency independent and
we want to see it below this Dash Blue
Line okay
um this one's a headphone amplifier so I
won't go into that so that's an
assessment of all the measurements but
with uh for state-of-the-art I recently
tested this in motiva erc4 CD player and
they only wanted me to test the uh DAC
portion of it and so that's what this
this is this this is about so please
don't complain that why I didn't measure
the CD portion all the test signals that
I mentioned are 24-bit in the other
imagine in the other overview and if the
CD cam Place uh 24-bit so everything
degrades if I measured from CD anyway
a little bit of preface in my reviews if
I find issues I report them in this case
I couldn't I could turn on the CD player
but it would do nothing else it wouldn't
open this drawer none of the controls
worked on the remote control or the
front panel so I had to take the top off
and looked in there and I found this
ribbon cable had come halfway loose it
looked like it was fully connected but
it had slid loose so it was not snapped
all the way in didn't have a locking
connector didn't have some glue to keep
it down and in shipping or otherwise or
maybe they didn't push it all the way in
it had come gradually loose so I had to
fix this I'd say about five percent of
time I have to go fix something before I
can measure it uh on this thing so it's
not a fun part of the job where you put
this thing in there and turn it on pull
your hair out for you know for 20
minutes trying to figure out why you
can't get the device to work anyway
um let's look at the dashboard now same
dashboard that we looked at
um balanced output XLR output look over
here instead of four volts we can 2.1
volt why it's like there's no Rhyme or
Reason for this thing to Output 2.1 volt
out of the blue uh four volts what it
should pronounce so you see me noting
that that it happens too low then I'll
look on the look on the right side and
look at how dirty this spectrum is
versus what we had just looked at if I
go up here and I'll scroll toward the
all the way up and look at the uh clean
this spectrum is over here and now look
at the Spectrum over here now I expect
to see stuff on the right side because
they're harmonic distortions multiples
of of this but then stuff on the left is
always puzzling because that's not
harmonic energy it's lower frequency so
that doesn't make sense I can't figure
out why this is there's like 600 Hertz
plus 600 Hertz doing over here it's
probably some kind of interference
inside the unit some micro processor
running at that frequency doing
something causing a spike and then as I
was watching in this red channel would
dance up and down come down go up then
come down
um very puzzling a lot of time this
comes from noise bleeding over USB from
a computer the USB interface is not
clean and it's the job of the deck to
filter all that and somehow it does it
for one channel but not the other ones
some kind of grounding issue internally
to the DAC so not good and what's the
penalty and all that
over here in the sign out see the sign
out it's not 120 DB anymore it's down to
94. and then I plot this thing in here
and this thing this I chart you can't
see it because it's got 400 Dax in here
but I put a little tick mark in where it
landed so it landed in this Orange area
so I have red orange green and blue and
those the top 20 are you know way out
here on the left so we clearly see it in
this lands in a fair category meaning
that it's not completely broken but uh
you know surely in this day and age for
I think it's a six seven hundred dollar
uh CD player on DAC it better at least
Landing good very good if not you know
excellent to land in this fair and
certainly in poor area it's just bad so
it's not that we put a lot of value on
sign up per se but you know when the
number just lands in a table and you
know itself incriminates itself but I
said look this is all the effort I did
uh you know why wasn't the design liner
measuring and saying hey why the heck do
I have all this garbage coming out of
that it's nothing musical about this
garbage by the way don't fall for this
thing about you know Distortion can be
euphonic no
99.9 percent of time Distortion now
you're finding certainly this is not
euphonic this is not euphonic and noise
that goes up and down it's not too far
okay as before I measure the RCA output
also you know it's got the same problem
so nothing new in here I measured the
dynamic range and uh instead of 20 bits
that's my threshold and I'd like to 20
120 DB over here and 20 over here uh
we're getting only 99 now 99 is better
than a CD CDs 96 and reality is about
93. so this is almost good enough for a
CD player function but it's not good
enough for uh as a DAC you can get again
very cheap tax that run circles around
this
XLR has just a tiny bit of improvement
lands at 17 bits so for 16 big content
you know not enough margin there but
okay so if you have very low standards
and maybe you bought this thing used for
a hundred dollars would be okay but if
you paid full price for it I would feel
bad now look at this linearity remember
I said this has to be a you know flat
line
it kind of is a flat line when his job
is easy but as the signals get smaller
and smaller they get subjected to error
and noise and look at how messy it is so
you know if I look at it and I measure
it when it's lost half a DB and that's
when I compliant so this thing is around
minus 110 so as a practical matter is
not an issue as an engineering manner it
should be better but anyway wherever it
starts to be bad enough I measure that
unexplained that if this thing is good
to 18 beds 18 bits is better than 16
bits so for CD playbacks okay but as a
you know comparing to all those
competitors is pretty poor
um now look at where our intermodulation
noise land remember I said this is the
10 or 15 dongle this is a you know four
Euro 250 device and we want to beat the
blue line and look at this this is
landing in the middle of these two which
is not good I'm more than that instead
of keep getting better it starts to tilt
up and Distortion takes over so there's
something in there that's causing
Distortion that lands at around minus
115 DB that's not good I expect this
thing too if it's going to tip up I
wanted to tip up just at the end but not
this early so nothing to hang a hat on
look what happened to our Jitter look at
the noise floor now instead of being at
the bottom in here it is come way up
here and then it's got all these garbage
spikes some of them are Jitter whenever
they're symmetrical from on both sides
of the signal they usually are Jitter
but some of them are not like these two
signals are not Jitter they're just
spikes that just happen to be there and
uh it's just bad and it's it's uh by the
way it didn't matter which input I use
so it's not a fault of the input you
know processing that's causing General
so you quickly see a problem
um this stack doesn't give you a choice
of selecting different filters even
though the internal that actually
probably has different filters they've
chosen not to expose it and which is
fine if you pick one of those good
filters and as far as their overall
response is okay as far as where it cuts
off but look at where it lands instead
of going all the way down here it stays
way the heck up here that means it's not
able to attenuate the ultrasonic energy
that shouldn't be there and what does
that mean when we measure the the 20 to
20 kilohertz with a wide bandwidth of 90
kilohertz meaning that we include noise
and junkness all the way up to 90
kilohertz this comes back to haunt you
because that means that filter is not
working well and look at what happens as
frequencies go up we get more and more
junk in the ultrasonic range and look at
the graph comparing to our Cheapo
reference 99 deck from four or five
years ago it loses to that and loses
badly on that so on a poor engineering
now note what I said early on in this
that I said whenever you get that sign
at is a great predictor or a good sign
of the rest of the measurements and that
you could have really just stopped in
here and you've seen proof of that in
here so clearly and same with the other
review that I showed you uh poor poor
Dak instead of having 115 120 DB you
only got 94 and every measurement from
there was bad look at this look at this
look at this look at this so that's how
you can speed read this stuff and that's
why sign out by itself may not be
perceptually super important but as a
predictor of how well engineered the
device was uh you know it's a good way
to to uh to judge something so and
that's why membership keeps talking
about what's a sign out of something
because they know that means a device is
well engineered well measured or not so
you know you can see comments in here
where I say 99 DAC would run circles
around this thing though little bit
about my recommendations this question
comes up I finish every review with a
recommendation when I did my first 10
reviews I didn't people kept asking me
so what do you think so what do you
think so I provided judgment my judgment
is all inclusive means I sit back in a
in a contemplate what uh what did I just
see in here uh usually I ignored price
but not always for example if you show
me state of the art performance and the
devices twenty thousand dollars that's
great I still recommend it but if you
charge five thousand dollars and produce
crap results I will take that into
account that you charge me so much money
on top of giving me bad results but in
general I'll look at this as if you I
was a mechanic it took me to shop or use
car with you on look at it look at all
the problems explain it all to you but
at the end you turn to me so would you
buy this for yourself
that's what this is I tell you if I
would buy this for myself if I had a
need physician device I certainly would
not buy this this that uh the DAC in the
CD player uh for five for six hundred
forty dollars or whatever it is or for
any money really I would do without if
this was the only one out there uh
fortunately is that and uh so that's
what this is now memberships often
complains about this as hey you were too
harsh or you were too easy I said fine
so I started a new mechanism which is on
top which is you all get to vote if you
remember and you can see 118 people or
85 percent voted as as this being very
poor and the next one's less poor and
then you know fine two people thought it
was okay and nobody thought it was it
was great uh people complained about
this saying how dare you judge something
without uh having owned it and played
with it and the answer is simple you're
looking at the same data more or less
that I'm looking at to make my own
judgment which is you know you have
objective measurements this is real data
tells you if this thing is performant or
not if it's well engineered or not what
the price is I talk about issues like
reliability and features and you know
you all get to judge if you think you
should judge it some other way you can
or if you don't want to vote you don't
have to vote if you want to ignore this
ignore it but oftentimes this tracks
more or less what I think but sometimes
people disagree and it's interesting to
look at the ratios in here what the
consensus of the communities
okay so let's see uh this took 38
minutes but uh you should be able to do
this work in three minutes now just look
at the deck go on audiosaurusreview.com
and click on this reviews tab on top
over here and you'll see all my recent
reviews and then just you know some of
the speakers and stuff you you can't
look up by the way there's a lot of
commonalities you know I'll cover
amplifiers and things but you can see
the same sign ad you see the same graph
so a lot of commonalities if you learned
this one about Dax you also learned
those but I'll do a speed reading on
those and hopefully those will go faster
on this one okay see you in a future
video bye